Miss Dior: Resistance fighter, Ravensbruck
survivor
Christian Dior is one of the most iconic names
in fashion — so iconic that even those with
zero fashion sense have heard of him.
His most popular line is arguably the equally
famous Miss Dior, and while everyone's heard
of the floral perfume, not everyone knows
that there was a very real Miss Dior — and
her first name was Catherine.
The perfume was launched in 1947, and when
Christian Dior wrote his autobiography just
a few years later, he said the name came to
him in a moment of inspiration, when he heard
his mentor greet his sister with the words,
"Voila, Miss Dior!"
In a way, it was a fitting honor.
Catherine was, by all accounts, one of her
brother's biggest supporters.
But on the other hand, she was perhaps the
last person one might think would lend their
name to a perfume.
Her contemporaries knew her more for her unconventional
nature and, when push came to shove, her fighting
spirit.
She was born in 1917, and as a young woman
living in France during World War Two, well,
that fight and determination served her well.
By the time the war came to a close, she would
become a highly decorated member of the French
Resistance, even though she would spend those
final, dark days as a prisoner in a concentration
camp.
A garden of peace before the horrors of war
The lives and work of both Christian Dior
and his sister would have one consistent theme:
a love of flowers and gardening, garnered
from their mother, Madelaine.
The family's early years were peaceful, idyllic,
even.
The Dior patriarch had provided well for his
growing family, accumulating a certain amount
of wealth as a producer of fertilizer.
They were well-off enough to keep more than
one home, but the one they remembered most
fondly was a family home called Villa Les
Rhumbs in Granville, a beautiful seaside resort
town in Normandy.
That was just a second home by the time Catherine
was born in 1917, and for most of the time,
the family lived in Paris.
Still, the young Dior siblings had their childhood
shaped by the extensive gardens and flowers
they remembered their mother patiently growing
and cultivating, an influence that would become
evident in later years.
Not all good things seem to last, though,
and it was certainly true for the Diors.
Christian, in particular, was of a superstitious
nature, and would later recall the very instant
the tide of their lives changes: the moment
that a mirror fell to the floor in their empty
house, and shattered.
"Misfortune came into our hitherto happy and
sheltered family immediately," he would write.
One of their brothers grew ill, and their
mother "suddenly faded away and died of grief,"
Christian would remember.
Brother Bernard would be committed to an institution,
where he would live until his death in 1960,
and suddenly, the wealth they had long enjoyed
was gone.
The Dior patriarch lost everything in the
Stock Market Crash of 1929, Christian's modernist
art gallery went bankrupt, and he was diagnosed
with tuberculosis.
Amidst it all, he found himself caring for
his siblings — including his favorite, Catherine.
The family moved to a small piece of property
in Callian, an area appropriately well-known
for growing the flowers that supply France's
perfume industry.
It was there that Christian began to draw,
selling his sketches to help support his family
and finally heading to Paris to enter the
design world for the first time.
Catherine followed him in 1936, and worked
at a nearby boutique.
It was their first foray into the adult world,
into the realm of Parisian fashion and industry.
But again, the good times were not to last.
War was lingering on the edge of everyone's
minds, and by 1939, businesses were closing
as people prepared for what they knew was
inevitable conflict.
Christian was conscripted into the military,
and Catherine returned to her father and Callian.
Her brother joined them fairly quickly after
he was demobilized in 1940, and here again
their lives intertwine.
They grew vegetables, helped supplement the
meagerness of wartime supplies, and made regular
excursions into Cannes, where they were kept
apprised of all that was going on in the war..
They were on the outskirts of the conflict,
but they would not stay there for long.
French Resistance, a chance meeting, and a
married man
On June 14, 1940, the day that so many Parisian
businesses had been preparing for finally
happened.
Suddenly, the city was under a strict 8pm
curfew, and German troops were announcing
their official occupation.
An estimated 2 million people had already
left ahead of the impending invasion, and
for those that remained, life was… complicated.
Parisians needed to find a way to co-exist
with their occupiers, and some — like Paris's
other world-famous fashion designer, Coco
Chanel — decided the best way to get through
the war was to collaborate with the German
military.
She dated a high-ranking member of the Abwehr,
moved into the Paris Hotel Ritz, and was given
her own code name even as she used the ongoing
persecution of the Jews to renegotiate some
business deals.
Catherine and Christian Dior did the opposite.
In 1941, Christian headed back to Paris, leaving
his sister at Callian.
He secured a position at the fashion house
of Lucien Lelong, and Lelong did an incredible
thing.
Even as Nazi officers informed him they were
going to be moving all of Paris's fashion
industry to Berlin, Lelong first argued that
it just wasn't possible to move the thousands
of skilled artisans to another city.
You couldn't retrain them, either, as it took
decades to become as skillful as his employees
were.
So, he argued… fashion needed to stay in
Paris.
Germany relented, the fashion industry remained
in Paris, and Lelong saved thousands of industry
workers — many of whom were Jewish refugees.
Even as Christian established himself in the
industry as one of Lelong's most valued employees,
Catherine was back in Callian.
It was the same year she did a seemingly innocuous
thing that would change her life.
It was November of 1941 and she went shopping
for a radio in a store in Cannes.
It was on that perfectly ordinary shopping
trip that she met a man she would fall in
love with.
His name was Herve des Charbonneries, and
he came with, well, some baggage.
He was married at the time, to the mother
of his three children.
Lucie — who was rumored to have had plenty
of affairs of her own — didn't matter, though,
not when it came to the blossoming love between
Herve and the young Catherine.
It was more than a simple wartime fling, though:
he and Catherine didn't just fall in love,
they joined a British-sponsored section of
the French Resistance.
It was called the Famille, or F2, and it was
cooperative intelligence network that had
been set up by French and Polish intelligence
officers in the summer of 1940, with some
help from the British.
She officially joined on July 1, 1943, just
a few months after Lucie.
It was dangerous work — it was the first
branch of the French Resistance devoted to
gathering intelligence, and they were doing
it under the nose of a Vichy government so
sympathetic to the Nazi cause of extermination
that they didn't just comply with the Nazis
— they went above and beyond to identify
members of their Jewish population.
Catherine became an intelligence agent with
the Massif Central unit; most of her work
was gathering and passing along information
on the movement of Germany's troops and weapons.
Reports were sent to London, to the Allies,
and to the troops who were under the command
of General De Gaulle; Catherine, now 29 years
old but looking a decade younger, spent much
of her time of her bicycle, attracting the
sort of attention a pretty young girl riding
along through the French countryside would
tend to get from the men she cycled past.
It was a nearly ideal cover, and it allowed
her to travel throughout the area fairly freely.
When she was in Paris, she would often stay
with her brother at his apartment, and even
as close as they were, it's unclear whether
or not she ever told him what she was doing.
It was, after all, the sort of thing he was
better off not knowing about — especially
considering he spent his days designing dresses
for the wives of the Third Reich.
Safety was, of course, first and foremost,
and if she didn't tell him, it was a secret
she kept to protect him.
The stakes were high, and to say what she
was doing was a matter of life and death is
no exaggeration.
In later memoirs, Catherine would remember
one day in particular that she met a friend
— and fellow resistance member — Liliane
Dietlin at a cafe.
She hopped off her bike and hugged her friend,
tightly enough that Dietlin remembered that
moment even 35 years later.
She asked Catherine about it, and Catherine
remembered, too.
She had delivered four messages that day,
three in the morning and one in the afternoon.
Eight people had been arrested.
Most would be tortured, and all would be executed.
When asked if there were many days like that,
she responded with a sad shrug and simply
said, "Ah, oui."
It wasn't just the enemy they knew about,
either.
By the middle of 1944, counter-intelligence
officers loyal to the Germans and to the Vichy
government had infiltrated F2.
Suddenly, no one could be trusted.
Hundreds of French Resistance agents were
arrested, torture was common, and Catherine
would have seen the bodies of her allies recovered
from where they had been dumped in the streets.
July was a particularly bad month.
Dozens of agents were arrested, including
Jean Desbordes., who went by the code name
Duroc.
He was taken on July 5, and held for four
days of torture before his body was recovered.
He had been beaten to death, his eyes torn
from his head.
Catherine was arrested on July 6.
From haute couture to concentration camp
When she showed up in Trocadero Square, she
thought she was keeping an appointment she'd
made with a colleague in the resistance network.
Instead, she was met by police under the direction
of a German French Foreign Legion veteran
named Friedrich Berger.
Berger had set up a base for his operations
in a wealthy Parisian neighborhood, and his
unit of intelligence officers were known for
such brutal torture that Allied officers estimated
that the longest their most hardened, well-trained
operatives could hold out was 24 hours.
Catherine was in custody for several weeks,
and when other prisoners were asked what had
happened behind the closed doors at 180 Rue
de le Pompe, they said that she never broke.
Berger's unit was so efficient at uncovering
French Resistance members that it wasn't long
before Catherine needed to be moved to another
secure holding facility to await transport
to her final destination.
On July 27, she was taken to the nearby Fresnes
prison — and this is a case of a few days
making all the difference in the world.
Berger and his men would flee Paris on August
17, and before they left, they shot and killed
the 44 prisoners they were holding.
Christian, meanwhile, heard about his sister's
arrest.
Even with the contacts he'd made through the
fashion house, he wasn't able to get anyone
to help secure her release… until it was
too late.
On August 15 — just 10 days before the liberation
of Paris — Catherine was forced onto a hot,
overcrowded train with more than 600 other
women.
Their final destination was Germany, and in
this case, time was not on her side.
Christian had succeeded in getting through
to the Swedish Consul General located in Paris,
and they were willing to speak to the Germans
on her behalf.
Raoul Nordling had already made some impressive
strides: he had already convinced German authorities
not to carry out Hitler's orders to destroy
the city, and he had secured the transfer
of political prisoners into Swedish custody.
And Catherine Dior was very nearly included
in that deal.
She was on the train, carrying a suffocating
stench of death that was so strong, the guards
riding on the roof couldn't stand it.
Nordling got permission to get her off the
train, as long as he could get a phone call
through to the SS officers when they stopped
at the station in Bar-le-Duc.
He couldn't get through, and the train kept
going.
Catherine was routed to Ravensbruck, where
she was examined, her head was shaved, she
was tattooed with the number 57183RA, and
given a uniform with the inverted red triangle
that denoted her as a political prisoner.
The waking nightmare of Ravensbruck
Catherine never freely spoke of her time in
the custody of the Nazis, and it's not surprising.
The atrocities of Ravensbruck perhaps aren't
as well-known as those of camps like Auschwitz
— a sad fact that historians say is a result
of the camp's location in what became East
Germany, as well as the fact that it was for
women, and not nearly as well-publicized when
it was liberated.
But it was no less horrible.
More than 130,000 people were sent to the
camp, according to best estimates, and surprisingly,
only about 26,000 were Jewish.
Others were political prisoners like Catherine,
some were academics deemed too dangerous to
be allowed to speak freely, and some were
simply sent there for not conforming to the
Nazi ideals of race and feminity.
Ravensbruck was a work camp, and historians
do know that Catherine worked at a number
of nearby factories that relied on slave labor
sourced from the camps.
She made explosives at Torgau, was forced
to labor in a Prussian salt mine, and worked
at a factory building parts for aircraft.
And she was also part of a group that attempted
to sabotage production in those facilities.
It's unclear whether or not her subterfuge
was ever discovered, but sabotage was common
enough that there was a standard punishment
for anyone caught doing it.
They were sent to the Bunker, a series of
dark and suffocating cells where troublemakers
would be left to languish away in solitary
confinement… after the beatings and whippings,
which had been approved by Heinrich Himmler
himself.
Those that were dishing out the punishments
were very good at it — Ravensbruck was the
training facility for the female guards of
the Nazi war machine, and some of the most
notorious women of the Third Reich got their
start there.
Irma Grese, later named the Hyena of Auschwitz,
was already gone by the time Catherine arrived,
but Dorothea Binz — who would later stand
trial for crimes like murder and setting her
dogs on the prisoners — was still there.
Conditions were dismal.
Catherine was just another one of countless
women who were given nothing but rags to wear,
offered nowhere near enough to eat, and, as
the blizzards and bitter cold winds of winter
descended, it quickly became clear that the
dangerous conditions of the factories and
their disease-ridden lodgings were not the
only dangers they faced.
Outbreaks of tuberculosis and dysentery were
common, and so were the medical experiments.
Polish prisoners were known as "rabbits,"
and were often maimed to simulate battlefield
injuries.
Most didn't survive.
A gas chamber was built there in February
of 1945, and thousands had already died there
by April.
An adjacent camp, Uckermark, was built for
the old, the ill, the weak, and as an execution
grounds for those found guilty of espionage.
Catherine, however, was already gone by the
time her fellow prisoners began to be sent
to the gas chambers..
She and a small group of French prisoners
were transferred out of Ravensbruck in February
of 1945.
They were herded onto freezing cattle trucks,
and stayed there — with no heat, no food,
and no water — for several days, until they
reached Markkleeberg.
There, they found they were going to be subjected
to an all new sort of hell — hard, outdoor
work in temperatures that dipped well below
freezing.
She stayed there for months, until new orders
were handed down on Friday, the 13th of April,
1945.
It was just weeks before Ravensbruck would
be liberated by a Soviet army who would find
just around 3,500 prisoners still at the camp.
The others were all dead or — like Catherine
— told to start walking.
They were under the watchful eye of SS officers
who had simple instructions: shoot anyone
who tried to escape.
So they walked… and around 115 kilometers
— or about 70 miles — later they came
to the city of Dresden.
It lay in ruins; it had been the target of
Allied bombers only a few months before, and
even today, no one is sure of the death toll.
Anywhere from 35,000 to 135,000 people were
dead, and the city that had once been called
"the Florence of the Elbe" had been all but
destroyed by thousands of tons of bombs and
incendiaries that had set off a firestorm
that engulfed military targets, railways,
museums, and civilian homes with equal enthusiasm.
Walking into the smoldering ruins of a city
that had once been one of Europe's most beautiful
destinations had to be heartbreaking.
But still, Catherine somehow managed to slip
away from the group, take shelter among the
ruins, and hide until the SS had marched away.
On April 19 — a week after she had been
marched out of Markkleeberg — she was found
by a group of American soldiers.
She was still near the bombed-out ruins of
Dresden, and when they took her to a hospital
for care, she would be there for the next
month.
Meanwhile, Christian had gotten word that
her name had been discovered on a list of
concentration camp prisoners, but it wasn't
clear where she was, if she had been among
those liberated… or if she had been among
the dead.
In an odd twist, he received that message
on April 19 as well.
For weeks, the only assurances he had that
he would once again see his beloved sister
came from the clairvoyant he regularly consulted.
Madame Delahaye had been unwavering in her
insistence that Catherine would return from
Germany, and it wasn't until May 27 that he
got another message — one that said she
was, indeed, coming home.
Homecoming… and immortalization
Catherine was back home in Paris the day after
her brother got the message telling him that
she was alive, and she was one of many on
a train of refugees bound for Paris.
She was a shadow of her former self, emaciated,
unable to eat solid foods, and suffering from
what we now call PTSD.
She wasn't just reunited with her brother
— also waiting to greet her was Herve de
Charbonneries and his children; based on the
accounts of friends, they put their lives
back together, built a family of their own,
and Catherine was allowed to live on in something
they described as "relative peace."
While she rarely talked about what she went
through during her imprisonment, she did testify
at a military tribunal in 1952 and as a strange
sort of footnote to that, Friedrich Berger
didn't stand trial for his actions in breaking
up the French Resistance by torture and murder.
He had been captured by British forces, was
eventually handed over to the Americans, and
went on to work with the secret service.
As for Catherine, her work in the Resistance
and her bravery in the face of torture was
recognized.
She was awarded a slew of medals, including
the Croix de Guerre, the Combatant Volunteer
Cross of the Resistance, the Combatant Cross,
and — from Britain — the King's Medal
for Courage in the Cause of Freedom.
She was also named a chevaliere of the Legion
d'Honneur, and, of course, Christian would
name his first perfume for her just two years
after her return to Paris.
And, she stayed busy.
She became a representative in cut flowers
and for more than a decade, she and Herve
would arrive at the Hallas market at 4am to
set up their display of cut flowers brought
into the City of Lights from all over the
world.
She and Herve lived together until his death
in 1985, and for years, she faithfully attended
an annual memorial service for members of
the French Resistance.
Even throughout her later years, she remained
steadfast in her support for the cause she
had nearly given her life for: She publically
distanced herself from the more controversial
members of her family, including her niece
Francoise, who just as publically declared
herself a neo-Nazi when she married British
extremist leader Colin Jordan in a ceremony
that involved a copy of Hitler's Mein Kampf.
Christian Dior died in 1957, and afterwards,
Herve and Catherine moved back to Callian,
where it had all started.
She grew roses destined for inclusion in the
perfume her brother had named for her, and
went on to help establish the Dior Museum
in the Granville home they had grown up in.
She never returned to Germany, and passed
away in 2008.